ah yes this next performer
she really lights up the banana more
stage
thank you mitzi ah i love you
hey everybody um thank you so much i
can't believe you all stayed in to see
me this is absolutely amazing um
i've been really trying to focus on the
positives this year you know
i'm actually so so excited about online
school
but i have a lisp and
bad coordination when i run i have the
gate of a poorly constructed marionette
also i'm pretty sure i'm flat-footed and
last year i got stuck in the bathroom
stall in school and i missed the
entirety
of our orientation pizza party not great
and it's because i couldn't do the latch
like it's actually like very very hard
you know right like it's just it's so
hard and that's why when someone walks
in on me i'm actually kind of relieved
you know like oh
thank god it opens people can have that
attitude more often like uh oh
hey you're here come on in it's awkward
but then again our country needs more
cordial conversation
that's why you know you feel free to use
this i
always carry around confetti so if
someone does walk in on me
i just make it a party surprise
no amanda she's the most popular girl in
my school she i mean she just is
but uh she was not having it with me
joining the
skinny babes group chat she was like um
who does she think she is and um this
year we have
no school pictures which is like a big
positive because i
hate school pictures and i mean it's not
even just school pictures
it's also like reshoot day which is when
your parents open up the envelope and
they look at the little photo and
they're like
no no i'm not i'm not paying for this
i'm just not
paying there i was on the reshoot line
seriously if it didn't work out the
first time
i have the same face yes
ah my mother would like to order the
reshoot
amanda's face please thank you
um that's not fair you know like we
really should be kinder to one another
and that's something i've learned a lot
during quarantine is that we really have
to be more understanding of people like
like you know i have to be understanding
of even people like like my mom who
who has a giant bag of socks that's just
been living in the corner of our living
room for years now
and i just have to be understanding of
that
but um i did confront her about it
the other day ago i was like hey mom
what's up with the bag of socks and she
was like
this is a bag of
socks i saved so you and your sisters
could make puppets
first i felt kind of bad you know never
freaking
occurred to me to make a freaking puppet
like i had no idea my mom was harboring
this dream of me becoming the next jim
henson
but then i was like wait a second
i've actually never shown a single
affinity towards puppets
so this isn't about me mom it's about
you
and then she got really quiet she went
why did i do it what did it get me
bags of socks me with a vacuum
glue and buttons what does it get you
what does it get you i had a dream
i dreamed it for you maybe
it wasn't for me maybe
um so now i'm making puppets
now please please visit my etsy page
uh thanks for having me thank you
thanks so much bye
i can't even get over how much talent
this person has it's downright unfair